some interesting discussions i spotted
this morning on the david pakman show
subreddit now you may or may not be
participating in this subreddit
uh we have nearly 30 000 of our viewers
and listeners subscribed
to our subreddit this is free i'm
selling you nothing
you can join the discussion at
davidpakman.com
slash reddit one interesting post points
out that the ceo
of right wing social media platform
parlor
has been fired and this is a wacky story
the trials and tribulations of parlor
sound like they would make a good
sort of like for uh limited run
uh dramatization on netflix in a netflix
original
now parlor which was briefly offline
after the riotous mob stormed the
capital
they now have fired their ceo john matsy
says he was removed as the chief
executive he didn't cite a reason
but apparently there has been a
significant
dispute within parlor as to how far they
are going to take their
so-called commitment to free speech and
open dialogue
and it's an absolute and total mess over
at parlor
a comedy of errors and who knows what
the future of that platform
holds um i did sign up the ceo this is
the guy who at one point said if any
prominent leftist with over a hundred
thousand twitter followers signs up
we'll give him 20 grand i said i i would
take 20 grand sure
i'm not going to turn that down signed
up and repeatedly
notified john matsey that i'm here and
i'm i've got a hundred and at the time
120 130 000 twitter followers
let me know how you want to send me the
20k and shockingly i never heard back
also another post from the david pakman
show subreddit an article about
canada listing the proud boys movement
as a terrorist group
indeed they are canada has announced
that
uh the proud boys and 12 other groups
are going to be designated as terrorist
organizations
some of these other groups we've
mentioned on the show before they
include these
radical right groups like the adam
waffen division
um and many others whose names are even
even more obscure
uh yeah canada is not uh messing around
here they are moving forward
uh powerfully and rapidly with getting
some of these groups listed as terrorist
groups now i
i lack uh enough of an understanding of
canadian law
to understand exactly what the legal
repercussions of this are but my
instinct is that the reason canada would
do this is not just
uh sociological but there that there are
law enforcement reasons to do this as
well
um in terms of prosecutorial discretion
or abilities when it comes to dealing
with such groups
although it would take a canadian legal
expert to tell me
more about it join the discussion at
davidpakman.com
reddit like i mentioned almost 30 000 of
our viewers and listeners
regularly participating on the david
pakman show subreddit there are
moderators so we don't allow
bullying we don't allow doxing or any of
that stuff so
join the party davidpakman.com reddit
if you ever feel like you just don't
have enough time to read all the books
you want to read
you have to check out one of my favorite
apps called blinkist blinkist takes
thousands of popular nonfiction books
and distills each one down into an
e-book
or audiobook that you can get through in
just 15 minutes where you're getting all
the key takeaways from the book
just imagine how you'll be able to
expand your horizons and knowledge
by being able to soak up all of the
important insights from 10 different
books in an afternoon obviously it's
perfect for exposing yourself to a new
book
you otherwise wouldn't have time for or
you can use it to revisit a book you've
already read
or use it to preview a book before you
buy the full version and read it
i recently read a brief history of time
of course by the great
stephen hawking this is a book that i
have been aware of for so long
and other things got in the way and it
was fantastic to check it out on
blinkist
blinkist has books on politics
philosophy science they have 27
different non-fiction categories and a
subscription is only about eight bucks a
month
and you get the entire library but
you can try it totally free and get 25
percent off a subscription
when you go to blinkist.com pacman
i've put the link right underneath this
video